Hugh Hefner was nine years old when he
started his first newspaper selling it
for a penny a copy it was the start of a
career that changed American society and
made him a global celebrity his Playboy
Empire brought sex and nudity into the
American mainstream when it was launched
in the 1950s and Hefner reveled in the
fame it brought him the concept is
essentially the same it represents you
know personal political economic freedom
I think that symbol is there and and
obviously represents sexual freedom and
represents a lifestyle of scale
lifestyle famously Playboy's interviews
were often as revealing as its photos of
celebrities and when Hefner moved the
Empire to Los Angeles his Playboy
Mansion became home to everything his
business represented the parties and the
lifestyle portrayed on TV there helped
fuel the mythology around Hefner pipe
smoking silk pajama wearing surrounded
by stars he lived there for four decades
selling the house last year on the
condition that he could spend the rest
of his days there that he did dying at
the mansion age 91 surrounded by his
family in a statement his son Cooper
said my father lived an exceptional and
impactful life as a media and cultural
pioneer and a leading voice behind some
of the most significant social and
cultural movements of our time in
advocating free speech civil rights and
sexual freedom but Playboy's treatment
of women always made Hefner a target for
criticism something he dismissed he'd
long since given up the day-to-day
running of the empire that made him
famous that he believed played a part in
the sexual revolution properly
understood playboy and the Playboy Clubs
were the end of sexism there was the
truth no matter the real sexist era came
before Playboy and playboy played a very
real part in changing all of that six
years ago he told a newspaper he'd
already paid for his final resting place
in a tomb next to that of Marilyn Monroe
Gregg Milam Sky News Los Angeles